this is a production of cornell
university
thanks for that uh nice introduction
gillian and um you know as i was
preparing for this talk
i realized that it was almost to the day
um
41 years ago that i gave my first
uh research seminar right in this very
room
but i think the the front of the room
was over there
in the back at that time
and so um i also remember and this is
not a great memory but like 10 minutes
before that i was down in the men's room
there like hyperventilating
and it was trying to keep from dry
heating because i was just so nervous
about giving a you know my first talk
and
fortunately things have gotten a little
easier over the years but
anyway perhaps more oops
more pertinent
remembrance from that time was also down
the hall here there's a little room that
contained a microscope a beautiful
zeiss
microscope i don't know if it's still
there even by the at the time it was the
late 70s and it was a
state of the art you know it had
differential interference contrast
optics nomarski optics
and it just was uh
just a great thing so and one one of my
uh office mates at the time
uh rick howard
had a project on that microscope so we
were working late one night and he
called me down to his uh
to his lab and said corby look at this
it's fusarium
and i looked through there
and it was like i was seeing living
things for the first time
it was this cell hyphal tip cell and i
saw a cytoplasmic streaming
i saw vesicles shooting back and forth
and i even saw a nucleus trying to
squeeze its way through through a septal
pore
and it just changed the way i thought
about fungi to actually see them and
maybe it's because i'm a you know a
visual learner
but um that made a huge impression on me
and i've always kept that in the back of
my mind that first time i actually seen
a living cell
in such detail
and so um
about 10 years ago i i guess i started
uh on this project i'll be talking to
you about today and it draws heavily
on microscopy
especially fluorescent microscopy and
and even super resolution and it
requires this uh
now state of the art
sort of imaging to really um
to make it uh possible
and
you know i work with
mycotoxins and it
it's um
it occurred to me a few years back that
the
although the
biochemistry of mycotoxin synthesis was
known
all the enzymes had been worked out some
of the regulatory processes
that no one really knew
what was going on in the cell where
where were these secondary metabolic
pathways occurring in the cell
so we we thought we'd give a look in the
system that i worked on
which is fusarium head blight
of wheat and barley
and it's caused by among other things
this fungus fusarium group in the arm
and when it infects wheat and barley it
causes
when infects wheat and barley
it causes these necrotic symptoms and on
weed especially it causes this uh kind
of spreading necrosis
within the uh the head
it turns out fusion and grooming
groundier unlike many fusion fungi
really prefers
to infect the head instead of the roots
like other fusarium
and
when it does that it infects the grain
and literally causes it to shrivel up
and blow away during the harvesting
process
but what brain
is left behind is often contaminated
with these
trichothesis and toxins
and these are important mycotoxins that
we really want to keep out of the food
supply
they they cause
elementary toxic leukea which causes
neutropenia
which basically does a number on your
immune system
and it also uh causes
extreme uh gastrointestinal
inflammation
and and that's never good
so uh
what uh
what we've been doing is is trying to
find ways of preventing
this toxin from accumulating
in plants
but uh
the toxin also is a virulence factor
during infection so if you make a mutant
of the fungus that does not create this
toxin
what you get is just a fungus that
causes a little necrotic flag at the
point of inoculation it doesn't spread
like this or cause such dramatic
necrotic symptoms
now what the
uh
the fusarium oh i should mention that
these are um these trichothesis are
sesquiterpenoid compounds so they're
made up of these five carbon units
that i'll describe in in just a moment
so these suspect terpene toxins like
deoxymobile
affect protein synthesis especially
during the elongation factor
process
at the ads
ribosome
and what this does when it produces it
in the plant is essentially
quell the induced response
of the plant
so
you get
it allows the fungus to colonize this
this challenged tissue
now during evolutionary time
the plants have responded to the
presence of this toxin
by creating a detoxification system
and these tend to be these
udp dependent glucoceal transferases
and what they do is basically
take
the dawn
and glom on a
glucose molecule at this 3 position
and it changes the biochemical character
of the molecule
and allows it to be
oh thank you
allows it to accumulate
in the vacuole and be uh form
further metabolize
now of course fusarium won't stand for
that so what they have done
is evolve
another secret sesquiterpene mycotoxin
and what it's very good at is inhibiting
this glucoceal transferees
reaction so although comorin
is not toxic itself it potentiates the
disease by
making the the concentration of dawn be
greater because it's not then further
metabolized
so these two mycotoxins really work in
concert
to cause disease in the plant
so suspect terpenes and terpenes in
general
are often primary metabolites they're
used in many
uh
processes that are required for all
cells to to live
and among the products that are
essential are things like progesterone
which is the major
sterol produced by fungi that's
important for for membrane function
ubiquinone which is important for
mitochondrial function heme and many
other primary metabolites
are the result of this uh biosynthetic
pathway that goes from
a steal coa
through the methyl on a pathway which
creates these five carbon
subunits which are then combined
into pharyngeal pyrophosphate
now pharyngeal pyrophosphate
is not only
the
starting point for all these primary
metabolites but also for these
mycotoxins now microtub the mycotoxins
that i i'm talking about today
are not constitutively produced rather
they're conditionally
produced to specific
molecules
and
conditions
for example
poly amines are very powerful inducers
of
these mycotoxins in culture
low ph is also an inducer and the the
the most potent inducer is actually just
inoculating these fungi and the plants
and
often
like point one percent of the dry mass
of infected tissue can be these these
mycotoxins so there's a lot of this
being made
upon induction then what you get the
first thing you get are these
soluble enzymes cytosolic enzymes which
take fluency of pyrophosphate and
cyclize it
and so this long borneo
uh synthase makes lunge borneo which is
precursor to comorin and
trichodine is a precursor to
the trichothesins
so the other induced components of the
pathway tend to be these integral
membrane proteins
generally
monooxygenases which
can cyclize but also create these
hydroxyl
decorations on the
on the molecule
so these
are predicted to be endoplasmic
reticulum
localized
so what does this sort of induction look
like in culture
what we did for this experiment was to
dfp label one of those
uh cytochrome p450 mono oxygenases try
one
and then follow it uh during induction
so we added this five millimolar
putrescine at zero hours and then you
can see it about 36 hours in this
western that it appears and then peaks
sometime after 48 hours
and you can follow it in a fluorescent
micrograph too so i don't know if you
can see this
these green dots here but certainly
at 48 and 72 hours you can see this
and this time course matches very nicely
to when the the mycotoxin
actually starts being produced in these
cultures
you can also see that there's these very
strange structures that are that where
the fluorescence is is localized these
crescent
shaped structures or circles
and
that was puzzling when we first observed
them and i'll get to that a little bit
later but
i should also say that the cultures
themselves look very different when you
induce them
they get thicker they become heavily
evacuated
and then they they branch quite a bit
and
they make these large swollen cells or
bulbous cells and i'll mention these in
toward the end of the seminar so this is
one of the consequences of induction
now within the cell
the organelle perhaps most altered is
the endoplasmic reticulum
and this shows a translation a
transmission electron micrograph
in a non-induced cell where the ers
primarily primarily exists as rough er
it's dispersed
it it's associated with ribosomes these
black dots
and
this is quite different than what we see
in these toxin induced cells
where we get this very elaborate smooth
er
these structures that
at times seem to arise from the nuclear
envelope
at times they are
in the peripheral er
but they're not associated with um
with ribosomes and what they are just
layers of er fold it back on itself like
ribbon candy
so there's just layer and layer
of these and in three dimensions they
look like sheets of course so you get a
better sense of that
in these three dimensional 3d renderings
this would be the nucleus
so um
it turns out that those very
unusual
fluorescent patterns that we were seeing
with the tri-1
enzyme here it is in the
in the pathway
corresponds to this modified er
so what we did was to uh
label several several of the enzymes in
the pathway including tri 11 now
and they showed
coflorescence to these structures here
here
and these correspond to the er based on
the fluorescence of this dye er tracker
which is
specific for er
in addition one of the enzymes but not
all of the enzymes of the mevylonate
pathway
is also found in this structure
as shown here
so because of the pathway enzymes all
being localized to this modified er
we refer to these organelles as
toxosomes because they're the presumed
site of toxin synthesis that's where all
the enzymes are
the only thing that doesn't really
follow that pattern so much was the the
first enzyme in the step which i
mentioned is cytosolic it's not
anchored to the membrane like these
other ones are
uh and indeed it's its fluorescence at
least at this resolution
does uh is consistent with a cytosolic
protein but we'll see in just a moment
that
it's more than just that
we always try to
make sure what we're seeing in cultures
corresponds to what we would see
during a plant infection
and so uh first of all i should
acknowledge marika burnish who's the
postdoc who did like 90 of the
micrographs in this
uh in this presentation just really
wonderful very careful work
so marika for a
d
work in germany in willie schaefer's lab
showed that the infection structures
of
fusarium gruminiarum these lobate
apersoria they're multicellular and
those also produce toxin these are
toxogenic cells
you can see they're kind of swollen and
highly branched
just like our
cultures induced
to produce toxins so these lobate
apersorion are on the surface of the
plant
then
you can see a similar structure
in a fluorescent micrograph
and here in red would be the toxosome
structure so each one of these
uh cells in the lobate episode contains
toxosomes
also a ton of
uh nuclei which is an interesting
observation as well
so the toxosomes are forming
not only in um
in culture but also in the plant
interaction and we've also shown that
these are not artifacts of the
fluorescent protein being there
using er tracker and super resolution
micro microscopy
so let's return to that cytosolic
protein tri5
trichodine synthase
so what we have here is a
super-resolution
uh
image of a toxisome labeled with with
one of these monooxygenases
and this is in a single focal plane
you can see that the
gfp
fluorescence
kind of fits over this toxosome as if it
were a helmet on a head and we can do
this
in
three dimensions
by taking multiple
focal planes throughout a cell
and then building that into a
three-dimensional model of the cell with
toxosomes
and i think you can see
how the green fluorescence seems to
envelop these toxosomes and really be
closely associated with them
moreover we can do optical sectioning
through those toxosomes
and show a coflorescence of the
cytosolic protein
with the uh
the red
membrane anchored
monooxygenases within the toxosome
so
what we believe is going on there is
that
the
tri5 protein really is being captured
between these success successive leaves
of the toxosome so as the
toxosome is forming these sheets folding
back on each other they capture cytosol
within them
and which leads to this co-fluorescence
meaning that they're certainly very
closely
uh localized
uh we wanted to do that for more than
just one cell because
if you look at one cell you can
cherry-pick and so we we did a
population of cells
i guess 91
and
to test whether or not there there was a
fendi for
the toxism for this cytosolic protein
we measured the
uh maximum fluorescence
within 250 nanometers of the toxosome
and compared that to the maximum
fluorescence of the same same enzyme
greater than a micron away from that
toxosome
and
we could express it as a ratio
you know if it's in the same cell
so a ratio of greater than one mean that
there's a
significant enrichment
uh for the cytosolic protein with the
toxosum and indeed we found that it's
significant and there's many where where
this is very much brighter
than um
than one
and as a control we we chose another
cytosolic protein
uh which um
which is also in the cell and it it
actually showed the uh kind of the
opposite
relationship
so you can really visualize this if you
uh imagine
focusing like you're looking through a
microscope and focusing down on the cell
so what we're doing here is just
focusing down on these cells
either labeled with the
tri5 protein
where you do see these
areas of co-fluorescence in every
section
versus this protein
where you see this is just cytosolic
there's there's no apparent interaction
so there is something special about
tri-5 being in there it's not just
your run-of-the-mill
cytosolic protein
so we're also interested in uh the
relationship
between primary metabolism metabolism
and secondary metabolism
so i said the cells make a lot of these
secondary metabolites when they're
induced
so when uh
when the fungus goes from a non-induced
to an
an induced state you can imagine there's
a lot of draw there's a lot of carbon
flow
that that goes that would ordinarily
just go straight to the primary
metabolites it's drawn off to these
other pathways
so
how does the
fungus adapt to those different pathways
occurring in the same cell
so
one of the kind of simple experiments we
thought to do is
if this was drawing from the same pool
of foreseeable pyrophosphate
if we deleted this
enzyme would that then lead to a greater
amount of comorin
and it's um tautomer
homeron
so
what we found actually when we did that
experiment is just kind of the opposite
because we thought that it might make
more tomorrow
to have more raw material to make it
but in fact what we found was just the
opposite
so this is a
gcms trace of the
volatile terpenes and culture headspace
of these cultures either wild type
or the deletion strain which is in gray
okay so here in the wild type you can
see the major trichothesin peaks as well
as as well as comorn
but in the deletion it's basically
flatline
so not only does it lose the ability to
produce trigonothesis
it loses the ability to produce comorin
which is a separate pathway that kind of
blew our mind
so
we were thinking that the the tri-fi
protein
embedded as it is in the toxism might
have some other
function maybe a structural function
so to test that what we did was to
create an allele of tri5
which was inactive so it lacks a
cofactor binding site so it's
enzymatically dead but it has the same
three-dimensional structure as tri5
so what
chris flynn did was to add that then
back
to the deletion strain
and what he found was that indeed this
this allele
restored wild-type levels of the comore
and
homeron production as well as some of
these other
sesquiterpenes as well
um
so this convinced us that it must have
some kind of either regulatory or
structural role
and the obvious place to look would be
at the toxism so in looking at the
toxosome oops
um
again with those same three mutants that
were in the
uh previous slide here's the
well the wild type fluorescently tag
strain
uh with the toxosome structures
produces don comorin
the deletion strain
the
uh this this is a hmg coe reductase
which is part of the toxizone
and it
um
the fluorescence here
looks as if it were the undifferentiated
er like we would see in in a non-induced
cell
so it's still going to the er but it's
not forming toxosomes
then if we put back the
inactive mutiny allele the toxosomes
reform
and we get comorin
so we believe that the toxosome may also
be essential for the comorin synthesis
as well as
tritathesins and and maybe other
sysproterbenes as well
our model is that um
based on the crystal structure of tri5
it
seems to exist as a homodimer
so we're thinking that the tri5 may
actually stabilize the toxosum structure
by forming some sort crosslinks
either to the uh
the reaction complex or to the membranes
themselves of the smooth er
and we now have mutants of of
sites we think might be important for
these sorts of interactions and
this is a project that's been held up by
the pandemic so
hopefully we'll eventually get these
these sorts of results and and test this
hypothesis
but overall what this is doing with this
means and the cochlear essence means
that
all of the enzymes of the
pathway are very in very close contact
with each other
and this may promote uh bio chemical
efficiency
having the intermediates all in a small
place but it also may help
because
remember these are toxic and
in theory they could inhibit the
protein synthesis even of fusarium so in
this way it sequesters the toxin as well
this is to show you that
the actin myosin cytoskeleton is
important for the formation of toxosomes
and this is based on the observation
that uh treatment with the trunculin a
which is a
uh effect and inhibitor
uh
greatly um
reduces the ability of the fungus to
produce toxosomes you can still see
fluorescence here so this
tricythesine protein is still there it's
just dispersed throughout throughout the
cell
and what this means is that
it produces much less
toxin than the untreated cell
there's another fusarium specific
inhibitor of myosin one
which acts with uh uh with actin
and it also has the same sort of effect
so here's this compound phenamico
again you see some fluorescence here but
not the intensity that you would see in
the untreated cells and the reduced
toxin amount
now phenamicryl actually is being used
in the field
in china
they're mixing it with tebuconazole
so this is a azole
fungicide which will kill the fungus and
then dynamic grill will actually greatly
reduce the amount of toxin that they see
in grain
probably because the toxosomes don't
form
so this is kind of an interesting
approach where you can have something
like financial which is not especially
toxic
but actually is targeting the microtoxin
synthesis
so i mentioned tebuconisol which is a
azoll
fungicide it acts on uh
ergosterol biosynthesis so we were
interested in where is that in the cell
compared to the tritocine pathway
is it in the same compartment or in a
different compartment
well it turns out this has been studied
in other organisms and
like in yeast
and there it looks like
these uh er gastrosynthesis also is
localized to the endoplasmic reticulum
but either to non-differentiated
uh er or to
these lipid droplets
so uh what has been observed is that
the the enzymes for its biosynthesis
are embedded in the er membrane the
product is actually
within the the two leaves of the
of the
bilayer of a membrane which will
eventually bleb out
and become a free organelle
with a pla a phospholipid monolayer
and with its fatty acid tails kind of
embedded in the
the lipid selvage
er dossier
so we want to observe these sorts of
things in fusarium to see if it's true
there
and we have a very efficient way of
viewing lipid droplets
using this dye body
nl which is for neutral lipids
we really see a constellation of these
lipid droplets
which also fluoresce with er tracker
again
showing that these are derived from the
er
and we can also visualize in the same
cell the toxosomes
and you can see the complete
non-correspondence of the lipid droplets
with the with the toxicity and that
would be shown in this land here
where it's either red or green but not
nothing is really co-fluorescing so
these do look like separate compartments
so then we want to see where the enzymes
go
and again this is another project that's
kind of come to a screeching halt with a
pandemic but i'll show you some
preliminary results here
and this is
the erg 11 protein
and using the dic or
nomarski you can actually see lipid
droplets as these
these little blebs here
and this is where the fluorescence for
erg1 seems to be
going
so that's consistent with erg 11 being
in lipid droplets
now erg one is a more complicated story
it looks like it's everywhere this was
the first step
in uh er gospel biosynthesis it's the
spoiling epoxidase
so it looks like it's in toxosomes in
undifferentiated er and also in lipid
droplets so i don't know if this is an
artifact or or what but
certainly it's something worth pursuing
if these um
these
primary and secondary metabolites really
are produced in different compartments
of the er
okay so
kind of the last part of the story is
how did the toxins eventually get out of
the cell
and
we wanted to address this by
first looking at some rna-seq data that
we had comparing non-induced with
induced cells
and we had in mind that there would be
certain
candidates or things that might explain
explain this one would be these
multi-drug resistance transporters like
abc transporters or major facilitator
transporters
and when we look at the
rna-seq data
comparing non-induced and induced
there's a lot of candidates to
to look at
and the other possible explanation is
that the toxins are being
packaged in vesicles
and then secreted by fusion of those
vesicles with the plasma membrane
so we looked at a number of genes for
vesicular transport and one that really
jumped out was this
sso2 protein
because of its location and where
what it's known to do
so sso2 is a snare protein so these are
membrane anchored proteins that really
are that kind of a target for vesicles
and they allow the fusion of vesicles to
the membrane where they reside
and it turns out that uh sso wants so
there's two of these two major of these
uh t snares in the plasma membrane
one sso1 which is essential for hip
growth
which would normally think about when we
consider the you know linear growth of
fungi
but there's this other t-snare
sso2
which is important for septum formation
uh branch initiation so branching as
well as the secondary wall formation
and the expansion of cells behind the
tip
so these are
found again in mature cells in the
septa this sso2
but they're not found at the tip as you
can see the fluorescence this
germinating
macrocanadium they're not out here
and if you remember
what i was saying earlier in the
the um
the seminar
that one of the curious morphological
changes that occur upon induction is
this this kind of sub-apical swelling
these bulbous cells
so we thought well this must be really
this process must be really accelerated
we know that
the gene is
highly upregulated
so anyway uh sean omar in my lab made
mutants
of sso2 and it's really
one of the most remarkable mutants i've
ever seen because it actually grows
faster than the wild type
uh and here you see this is i think
maybe
i don't know three or four days growth
wild-type and
sso2 mutant and obviously there's a
pigment difference
but there's also many many few or
of these bulbous cells per field
than in the wild type so here's the
mutant and
so it produces
about 70 percent fewer of these bulbous
cells
uh and interestingly it also produces
about 30 or 40 percent less dawn
than the wild type so
probably because it's just not getting
out of the cell
and um
but it's it's not everything because
there's still quite quite a bit of dawn
that is getting out of the cell so uh
sean looked at some of these other
candidate
uh multi-drug resistance proteins
and to show that they were actually
transporting dawn
what he did was to um
express the proteins in yeast and then a
yeast strain which lacks its uh
endogenous transporters so it's really
sensitive to everything especially don
so if you just put a
vector into that strain
and do a dose response curve
for don or in this case 15 a don
at
10 parts per million it's essentially
completely inhibited
and if we put in uh one of these
transporters abc1
it's it's quite resistant
to
those levels of dawn similar to the
endogenous
pdr5
multi-drug transporter that is found in
yeast so this is the the yeast one
here's the actually the fusarium
homolog of that
so the real proof is of what they're
doing is to
uh
delete them in the fungus from which
they came
so here you see dawn concentration
uh of uh the wild type
in this is in planta
the sso2 mutant reducing it a little bit
abc1 mutant reducing it quite a bit more
and then if you combine those two
mutations
reducing it even even further
so we think that both vesicular
transport and the multi-drug resistance
transporters like
the abc1 are important for getting the
toxin out of the cell and delivered to
the plant where it can be a virulence
factor
so i i heard a little bell go off i
guess that means i'm out of time but i
just want to
oh it doesn't that one did everyone else
hear that or is i just here
okay
all right well i don't have to rush then
so the just some of the conclusions uh
so there's this organelle
that we've felt that toxosome it's
organized smooth er
and it forms when whenever you induce
the fungus debris
to produce toxin it
appears to be required for
high level dawn production because
um
things that inhibit the
formation greatly reduce the
accumulation of dawn
and that this is a has potential for
for chemicals that can really target
toxin production i have a friend who's
in the pharmaceutical industry
and he does this computer assisted a
drug design
and he looked at the the
these results he says oh we could we
could make a
molecule that would be like
a hundred or a thousand times more
effective
than financial
so the the possibility is out there and
if it's much more potent than financial
then you had to you could add just
like very vanishing amounts of this
compound to inhibit the production of
the
dawn in the field
so we think that the uh
vesicular transport
may uh do two things sequester the
toxins from the rest of the cell
and then aid in its um
its secretion but it's not the whole
story that uh the
cells also require these uh
plasma membrane localized transporters
which effectively pump the toxin out of
the cell as well
well i have a lot of folks to thank
i think i i showed pictures of everyone
as i went along although i did i don't
think i mentioned everyone
but
especially i want to thank marika
bernice who's really
helped me
develop a cell biology program in my lab
and without her i don't think i could
have done it
and karen bros who's my
longtime lab manager who just knows how
to do everything she is just a terrific
asset to the lab
and then my
many
collaborators especially the imaging
unit at the university of minnesota
and of course funding sources
primarily usda nifa
so thank you i'd be happy to answer any
questions
i forgot to mention um thank you kirby
um reception on the egg quad following
this um
packaged food and drink
so
questions
enzymes weren't useful um
what happens
is it reversible can you wash out the
pre-putrazine and do those
er stacks
vanish
so for the people in zoom uh or repeat
the question
which was um is the process of toxosome
formation
reversible if you wash out the inducer
would you lose the
uh that structure
and the answer is i don't know that's a
good question
uh there's there's a lot to be answered
one one thing is that
if if you induce a culture to produce
toxin
you see the fluorescence for those
trichothesis enzymes
and only a small fraction of the cells
it's remarkable
so only certain cells will differentiate
like that not all of them and when one
differentiates then the chances of the
one next to it differentiating increase
so sometimes it begins in one and moves
down the line
um
but it's also important you know in an
infection
it would be important you would think to
regulate you know i can't just go in
there and
full time
uh that it would be important to down
regulate too and so
what happens next i don't know but
that's a really good question
yeah corbin i just wanted to uh ask a
little more about this potential
chemical pathway to suppress the
toxosomes
was that
something that targeted specifically for
toxosomes and not affecting the other
kind of
er organelle type of things but it would
have specific activity there
well it's specific because it only works
on the fusarium myosin one so any other
fungal species it doesn't work on and
it's because of the particular amino
acid sequence of fusarium myosin one
but it's it's it targets specific the
atp is the
site of the uh
of the myosin motor
yeah theresa this was beautiful corey
thank you um
i am fascinated by uh tri5
i got an impression that it was a
cytosolic protein but then you have a
model that it kind of crosslinks the
lamellae of
er
okay okay so um
the question is how can the trifid be
both a cytosolic protein
and interact with
uh with either membranes or other
proteins
well it um there are potential sites
where the
protein can be modified so
lipid adducts may be possible
and so we've created mutants that
change those amino acid residues
so that they would not act as those
sorts of potential anchors lipophilic
anchors
and we'll see what happens yeah but that
that's really a
major focus of what we're trying to do
next
like i say we have all the mutants it's
just
we need to look at them yeah
yeah hi yeah thanks kirby i'm sort of a
little bit related to maria's question
um
is do you know what the inducer is in
atlanta and is is there sort of natural
genetic variability in wheat or barley
for that inducer like that's a
susceptibility
yeah so the the question is uh what
potentially is the natural inducer of
toxin production in the plant and is
there a natural variability for that
in the plant
and
the answer seems to be that these
poly means like agmatine and putrescine
are likely the endogenous inducers and
that's because uh it's been and this is
all kind of correlative evidence but
because i don't think you can actually
eliminate the polyamine synthesis
without severely affecting the plan
but what um
what has been done this has been done by
don gardner in
australia
islam
so
first of all you screen all sorts of uh
compounds for their ability to induce
and by far the
the
strongest inducer of toxin synthesis
were the poly means especially petrosine
and agmatine
and then the observation that
when you add the fungus
inoculate the fungus to the plant
the
biosynthetic pathway enzymes
the genes for those enzymes in the plant
are upregulated
and also the amount of those
compounds are
increased
in the infected plant
so all these oh and then they have a
biochemical inhibitor of
polyamine synthesis one of the enzymes
and when you add that then there's less
less toxin produced in those
in those uh
inhibitor treated plants so all those
are kind of correlative evidence that
that this is really the endogenous
inducer of dawn
yeah
adam mutation effects called
you think the toxosomes are
evolutionarily ancient just a
structure for making all kinds of things
that might be toxic or do you think it's
something that evolved with
with the
genesis of these types of devices
so the question is
do we think that
the toxosome structure the
smooth er
arrangement
is specific
specifically uh arose evolved
to accommodate toxin production
versus some other
general process
well when we first observed that we went
through the literature searching for to
see if anyone else had seen anything
like this
and um
the thing that we found that that most
looked like it were hepatocytes
that were treated with toxic compounds
so that's a cytochrome p450 inducer like
benzanthusia
and in these
hepatocytes you see this elaborate
smooth er
so
and we know that cytochrome p450s are
induced in those hepatocytes
so
i think what what it is is the the cell
just needs a lot of er because there's a
lot er proteins to accommodate
and so it's just making
er and i suppose all cells have that
that capability
uh if they
if they are induced to produce so many
of these types of
enzymes
that's my guess anyway
so does anyone in the zoom audience have
a question
yeah my question is with the uh
the sso2 mutant
is the growth inhibition dependent on
uh
induction with putrescine
um
no
so those uh it's actually uh it's
enhanced growth
and it's it's present even
i'm sorry yeah
and it it's because that it just doesn't
branch
branches very little compared to the
wild type
so all its growth is directed outward
rather than forming these mycelial mats
and actually if you grow them in liquid
culture there's no difference in dry
mass
uh between the mutant right
so that suggests it's just the different
morphology of growth that's accounting
for that
right okay
okay yeah
just curious going back to uh
implantation
and any other thoughts on what might be
going on in plants
versus what you're seeing in vitro
well um
yeah so
as i mentioned
before in the question and answer period
not all cells are
toxogenic
and that's certainly the case during
infection so on the surface
you have run or hyphy
and those are undifferentiated
uh
and do not produce toxin and
they know that based on marika's work
from back in in lily shaver's lab so
what they did was to take
the promoter the tri-fi promoter and
link it to gfp
so whenever the induction
would be
found it would it would glow green
so they looked at these um
the fungus on the surface of the plant
the runner hyphae were not green but the
the um infectifies hyphae the uh
at persouria were
you know greatly greenish so that
indicates that
the toxin was just being produced at the
point of infection but
what goes on further into the plant i
don't know i mean that
i think it'd be a lot harder to do
yeah francis trail many of us heard her
seminar yesterday
and she talked a lot about the uh the uh
cells plant cells
with higher levels of silica
and
i don't know if you've connected those
dots at all if uh if that's uh
any way stimulating to uh
the toxin production
we haven't really looked at it so that
those would be at the trichromes or
something like that some other cell
types but particularly trichomes yeah
um
yeah you know when those experiments
that marinka did
uh
were done
it was before francis has worked with uh
celica so she didn't really address that
thank you so much
well thank you
[Applause]
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu